alvaro presses the treetle of a spinning
wheel with his foot it moves a bar up
and down making the wheel spin so just
to be clear what a treadle is this is an
old spinning wheel and this little pedal
that is a treadle and as this goes up
and down it's going to pull on this bar
which is then going to spin this wheel
which can then be used to essentially
power the machine
so it says the function b of t models
the height in centimeters of the top of
the bar when alvaro has pressed the
treadle for t seconds so it's telling us
the height of i can barely see where the
top of the bar is someplace over here
and this isn't exactly what they're
probably talking about in this exercise
here but this is just to give you a
visualization of what a treadle is and
what the bar is and then what the
spinning wheel is
alvaro has pressed those treadle for t
seconds so they give us b of t right
over here 90 minus 12 times sine of 5t
the first question is what does the
solution set to y is equal to 90 minus
12 times sine of 5 times 6
represent
pause this video and see if you can
think about that
all right so it looks like right over
here so we have the 90 90 12
12 and we're subtracting 12 sine of 5
times t 5 times t so this right over
here is t
so this is the solution the solution set
right over here tells us what is the
height because that's what b of t is so
b of t is equal to y what is the height
when t is equal to six remember t is in
seconds so this is height
height
of
top of bar top
of bar at
6
seconds
all right now we have more questions
here the next question asks us
what does the solution set to 95 equals
90 minus 12 sine of 5t represent pause
the video and think about that
all right so here they're saying that b
of t is equal to
95
and so the solution set you're really
solving for t
so you're really solving for all of the
times when our height is going to be 95
centimeters
so all
times
t when
height
of top of bar
of top
of bar
at
95 centimeters and that's going to keep
happening over and over and over again
as t goes forward in time so you're
going to have a very large you're going
to have an infinite solution set over
here you're going to have an infinite
number of t's at which your solution at
which the top of the bar is at 95
centimeters
now we have another question
this one is asking us what does the
solution set to y is equal to 90 minus
12 sine of pi over 2 represent so pause
the video and think about that
all right now this is pretty interesting
we can actually evaluate what sine of pi
over 2 is so sine of pi over 2 radians
or sine of 90 degrees that is going to
be equal to 1.
and so that's the maximum value that
this sine over here can take on now
we're going to subtract 12 times that so
this is taking on a max
then when you subtract 12 times that
this is actually the minimum value that
you can take on you're going to have you
can't get any lower than this
and so this is going to be the lowest
the lowest
height
for
the top
of
the bar
and we're done